uh 2021 bought the end of the
kardashians on e and the end of kim and
kanye in real life uh in the divorce kim
got the house and kanye got the stadium
that's right when they separated kanye
moved into atlanta's mercedes-benz
stadium this is actually kanye's room
let's take a look this [ __ ]
really did more yeah yeah
it looks like the women's gym at the
ncaa tournament look at this [ __ ]
remember they only had three weights
it looked like the olympic dressing room
thank you the box
only kanye look at this [ __ ] man then he
went to a game
later that night
that was on top of the stadium that he
was sleeping up under yeah well when
they said kanye what you about to do
after this i'm about to go downstairs a
little bit
what
yeah i'm about to go right into sleep i
ain't gonna do too much after this
i ain't trying to be up all night i'm
gonna go right downstairs go to bed tell
them they gotta wrap this basketball
[ __ ] up
i got a big day tomorrow
he was living there
kanye was spotted making an appearance
at one of those games we talking about
let's check it out
jesus christ
kyle got paint holes on his face
[Laughter]
kanye walked in that [ __ ] looking like
a bank robber from the 80s
put the money in the bag [ __ ]
luther
you know they could always see who was
robbing them in a penny hole say you jab
ass [ __ ] put the money in the bag
[Laughter]
i don't want to hear [ __ ] you got to say
if it ain't the money in the bag hey man
i know you you don't know me stop
looking at me man
just put the money in the [ __ ] bag
go roll with cliff again let me see what
he had on walking to the ship again
look at this [ __ ] here god damn it
god damn it kanye [ __ ] had on the eddie
murphy delirious outfit with a stocking
cap